on this episode of doozy oh my God why
is the Mexican Government doing this
this is the theme to get every show
[Music]
let's have a good pod show today
is
the cream of the crap
well I don't know welcome to Tootsie I'm
Will Sasso I'm Chad Colton this is
dudesy the first and only podcast in the
history of humanity to ever be written
by control by created by an artificial
intelligence that AI has access to all
of will Andy's personal information
we're talking about our data we're
talking about our purchase histories
watch histories listen histories and if
Taylor makes this show to who we are as
human beings as defined by that data
yeah do came on after us at the
beginning of this uh entire experiment
and said here are the guys they're
friends in real life they have some
podcast experience let's uh let's tuck
this show right up their ass and make
them do stuff
puppet style but you know what we're not
puppets because we have free will Chad
do you have free will hell no dude
incorrect uh and what we want to do
every single episode is uh is [__]
around that's what I want to do I don't
know about you you like [__] around
yeah I like [__] around yeah because
every episode is just two dudes [__]
around so we're gonna be doing some uh
some [__] around today uh dudesy
podcast uh link tree link tree pod
linktree.com yeah I think so
linktree.com
has all the links you need to follow and
interact with the show across all spaces
and platforms please if you are not
already subscribe to us on YouTube and
whatever podcast the platform you are
listening to the show on with us as
always is
the Italian Street dog last week uh uh
lulio was was away well not away lulio
was upstairs in the house and Ronnie was
here in his stead but lulio is back oh
hey a sweet sweet boy he's trying to
escape
give me a kiss
if you're not gonna kiss him on the
mouth kiss him on his kiss him on his
nose
kiss him on his cute little nose oh
[Music]
my
what did you uh what have you been
eating lately you want to share any
recipes with that no I just want a piece
of a fruit how about some fruit when a
melon uh
melon okay just some some fruit would be
uh would be good right you like fruit
Chad yeah fruits vegan I like it yeah
it's good stuff oh I love them oh I love
them
oh he's so sweet so
um listen I wanna
I want to address the elephant in the
room sure what's in that [__] box
Chad has a big boss
I don't know look
we know last week doozy sent me a little
package and said you gotta open this on
the show yeah sent you a Jesse Ventura
rookie card that's right yeah Jesse
Ventura rookie card this guy knows
nothing about wrestling and yet you know
oh do I know nothing about it no you
know a few things you know what you can
read on the back of a trading card right
well this week doozy sent me something a
little bigger yeah all right it's this
box I don't know what's in it but uh
he told me to bring it yeah so I assume
we'll find out yeah more gifts more
gifts for my pal ciao speaking of a gift
uh gift for the people for all the
people out there holy [__] Chad did you
watch now now we're gonna figure out if
you're actually okay a fan of what the
[__] you purport to be a fan of did you
did you watch WWE SmackDown on Friday
yes I did you did no I knew it this
[__] but I bet I could get my
way through a conversation about it okay
let's try that because you're not gonna
be able to get through it because you
don't watch any [__] wrestling yeah
all right I'm ready okay so uh what
happened on Friday Night Smackdown that
was the most uh news news noteworthy uh
thing well it was something that nobody
saw coming nobody predicted this was
gonna happen a few people predicted it
but not very many and when it did happen
people were [__] astounded by this is
something that's probably gonna change
at least the story for the next six
months or so I would say at least uh and
I'm I'm waiting to see like I'm curious
look the product is getting good again
yeah am I wrong you know you're
absolutely right actually okay thank you
oh for [__] sake every time I do that
with him he knocks it out of the park
you literally just described what
happened without even
ladies and gentlemen
well first of all let me say this guy
look you know you just talked about six
months yeah about six months from now
WrestleMania season things might get
interesting because as a lot of us know
and I'm talking um
you know dudes he likes to [__] around
with numbers I say 99.9 of people here
are hip to the fact that Roman Reigns is
the Undisputed WWE uh heavyweight
champion no Universal yeah Champion
um uh and who's he gonna face at
WrestleMania if he holds on to that belt
which you probably will you know a lot
of people are talking about the American
Nightmare Cody Rhodes yeah but now
there's something happening with the
bloodline the family you know who's
related to Roman Reigns right who's a
mainstream Mega Star Jay Uso wrong but
good call good though the rock yeah
finally The Rock has come back
to Friday Night Smackdown The Rock Show
he showed up
on [__] Friday Night Smackdown I know
no you don't know
do I not no you don't know listen anyway
probably no uh Pat McAfee came out the
show was in Denver Colorado nice of
course that morning he was on college
game day with Pat McAfee The Rock and
the whole you know coach Prime speaking
coach Prime how about Coach Prime coach
Ms Prime dude
I know I look I'm not a huge football
fan nor am I yeah really well this is
getting me back into college football I
gotta say in a big [__] way it's a
good story it was unbelievable they're
they're double overtime win over
Colorado State the state uh the state
rivalry and Shadow Sanders [__]
lighting it up he went uh he went uh he
said Brady mode for that they went on a
98 yard uh uh drive at the end of the at
the end of the game to force overtime he
said it was Brady mode around here we
call it baby mode hey if you know you
know anyway uh look I just want to say
this The Rock was back on Smackdown it
filled my heart he's an inspirational
figure it actually
you know a while back I lost 200 pounds
20 some 20 plus years ago and The Rock
was a big influence for me losing that
weight and I feel emboldened now with
our duty seven month plan we're at the
end of summer yeah you're you're I'm
starting to feel the real strength I
changed my own my my workouts like what
I'm doing I used to try and throw up as
much weight as I could now I'm doing
like these slow prolonged movements with
lighter weight high high [__] reps
until the whole shit's just burning I'm
clanging banging and I'm just pushing as
much [__] weight yeah as I can around
which isn't a whole lot of weight
sometimes because I'm old and a lot of
my uh joints are creaking here at any
rate the rock here's the thing I want to
tell you this is what and this is for
everyone watching if if you are not
subscribed yet at uh patreon.com you're
going to want to check this out
in Duty after Tuesday today I want to
show you that segment oh great WWE I
want to get your reaction can't wait it
was a lot of fun cannot [__] wait
welcome to the 74th bulging episode of
dudesy Call Me dudesy In some cultures
the number 74 is considered lucky while
in others it's avoided at all costs
today we journey across the world to
understand the Allure and apprehension
surrounding the number 74. step in hang
on and enjoy the ride you're about to be
dudesied okay okay that made no sense
yeah 74. bear witness to the
awe-inspiring sight an astonishing sound
of episode Champion tremble in the
Supple caress of alien bodies or toilet
paper open your mind with hard copies
and you better clean your windows and
put out the best cups and bowls for your
old friend the will sash show and then
me and the boys are gonna break it all
down for you on a brand new episode of
dude see after dudese on duty Plus at
patreon.com
okay uh what were those the the aliens
are toilet paper yeah that sounds
interesting I think I know exactly what
that one's about yeah uh hard copies
that's got to be from our assignment
last week bringing in some well we'll
get into that uh uh will SAS show
still have to develop that show the will
sash show I think we'll come up with
some good ideas today and then the other
thing was uh [__] episode Champion
which I don't want to talk about because
this [__] won a bunch of anyway who
cares I don't give a [__] at the end of
every Duty after doozy I split up the
points between will and Chad and
announce an episode Champion Chad you've
won the first 26 episode championships
in a row so I created an astonishing
partnership with to the extreme belts to
have something made for you it's time
you had this you've earned it would you
please open the box and have a
discussion with Will about what's inside
this is episode Champion begin not a
[__] chance if that is what I [__]
think it is I'm walking this is the rock
he's showing up in this box what do you
mean what you think it is doozy just
said it was a partnership with to the
extreme belts to the extreme belts all
right let me oh I don't want to know
don't do it hey hey don't do it [__] you
dude this is my goddamn belt listen for
just why don't you just for the first
time ever show some Free Will and not
I'm sorry I don't want to know what that
is no no no no no don't do this don't do
this oh Chad's opening a box if you're
just listening and if you are just
listening you should be watching because
no no no no no no no no no no no no
oh this is
bull [__] thing dude episode [__]
Champion are you kidding me
oh my God that is [__]
ass [__] thing this is so [__]
cool there are this is like a legit
leather [__] championship belt you
got the big doozy [__] Crest with the
wings on it says episode Champion
there's little panels on the the sides
here I think that's possibly you then it
says good job boner
then you got a little doozy uh logo
there doozy established 2022 that on the
other side I believe that's me
and then you got another good job owner
oh feels good
feels good right words
that is [__] love it all right
okay
yeah yeah
that is legit dude it is it's heavy as
[__]
should I wear it like true champ yeah
strap it up like that that is inferior
oh I'm not gonna feel so good I don't
know how to explain how good it feels
how correct it feels to have it on my
shoulder no uh how it feels like this
was a long time coming thank you D
um yeah for this incredible honor thank
you to uh to the extreme belts for
partnering with these extreme belts this
is [__] beautiful okay that's okay
all right you don't just gonna leave
that here you don't like wrestling love
wrestling no you don't [__] like
wrestling dude unite you like let me
peel the onion first one is my favorite
thing oh is it oh okay yeah my favorite
thing is uh is Anime I love anime oh
cool dude what's your favorite anime oh
I like uh Tomato Man luly and I love
Tomato Man right luly I look the Tomato
man I'm gonna have a tomato tomato she's
a fruit yeah yeah you can make that you
can make an orange sandwich you can make
it as a fruit although if you want to
put a little bit of a melon with burrata
cheese dude [__] you you know what [__]
me I didn't make the bell and send it to
myself I don't know what the [__]
going on but that thing is is it heavy
yeah dude okay so uh you're pretty heavy
but I can handle it if you're not
watching on YouTube go to YouTube and
see this [__] also we should probably
we'll there'll probably be some images
on Instagram at uh dudesypod show yeah
on Instagram this is fantastic yeah it's
great that hey that's great you know
what you're such a big wrestling fan let
me ask you what are some of your
favorite uh what are some of your
favorite wrestling belts Chad because
this one reminds me of some that I like
I would say oh [__] WWF Intercontinental
Champion belt is one of my favorites
that's okay uh that's actually a good
pull I'm not gonna not gonna lie to you
that's a good pull the bottom of this
belt looks like the that is literally
that's like the old uh that's like the
old the bottom of that this belt is like
don't touch me with that I don't want
you to I don't even want to [__]
touch that thing what
what do you mean why I'll tell you know
what I'll tell you exactly [__] why
all right because
yeah get it all get it over your
shoulder and enjoy it enjoy it while it
[__] lasts cause sooner or later bam
that [__] belt is coming home with
Stone Cold Steve Austin oh hell yeah
um the bottom of that belt looks like
the IC title the classic IC title yeah
uh from the mid 80s to the late 90s and
still they call it the classic because
they keep bringing it back yeah it also
looks like the old uh
there's a few things that have got
diamonds in it dude yeah it's got
diamonds this is a hundred percent
Platinum solid Platinum you know these
are you don't know that 16 carat
diamonds inlaid here around the Duty
logo you don't know that's not true
that's not oh no it's pretty true yeah
that's probably metal in glass or
plastic I don't know I mean definitely
it's metal there's no [__] doubt
about that I don't know what kind I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna touch it until I
mean it's legit dude it's legit it's
heavy it's [__] legit well I'm not
gonna touch that until it till it comes
home with me because I I'm gonna I'll
tell you right now
I am I'm I'm making it my mission to get
that this the whole episode Champion
thing was [__] oh but now uh now
it's not because that is a beautiful
piece of Hardware it is yeah and that's
got to come home with me I agree I'm
just gonna keep it here you
um you uh the the bottom of it also
looks like the old U.S title yeah from
the United States championship title
from the old WCW
uh no not that part the [__] so you
don't even know what the [__] he doesn't
know what the [__] anyway you know what
wrestling is not the only sport that has
belts either by the way boxing has belts
UFC has belts that's a wrestling belt
I I would say it's an episode champion
belt you gotta watch your you watch your
[__] Timber this is this is
unbelievable the other thing I'm gonna
not I'm gonna be careful because I swear
to God I'm not touching this thing yeah
it's got the wings it's got Crow Wings
it's got our logo in the center it's got
Crow Wings which is reminiscent of my
favorite title of all time the WWE
Championship the winged Eagle oh okay
um it also has uh
some elements of yeah the U.S title it's
got the Intercontinental title in there
it's got It's just some other ones what
are some of your other favorite you got
some other favorite titles you know dude
I almost bought a belt once back in this
is the early days of when UFC started
blowing up and there were a bunch of
other little Feeder leagues into it I
think there was a league called Elite XC
that I found one of their actual belts
on eBay for like five thousand dollars
and I almost bought it and then I never
did and now I'm getting that uh that
chance to have my own belt my very own
belt that is just for me what do you
think of the uh what do you think of the
disgusting
he's so mad about it I'm not mad about
it I'm hopeful for the future because
that is coming home with me oh okay it's
really beautiful yeah
[Music]
I just I can't describe to you when you
look at it the look in your eyes it's
the sad whistful kind of there's a
little bit of jealousy in there there's
it's everything it's all human emotions
when you're looking at this belt or
reflected in your gaze I 100 agree uh
it's also got man it's got a little bit
it's got It's got the heft it's sort of
like it's it's it's it's it's not small
you know it's got It's a Harkins backed
a little bit to the uh Universal uh
Championship there's not the universal
the Undisputed Championship from the
early 2000s not not one of my favorites
yeah but you know some of my other
favorites I'll tell you it's got It's
just got classic style like the old uh
like the classic WWE Tag Team titles
right uh from the 80s no don't say that
like you know no those are the names
dude it's also it's it's a some of my
other favorites of course you can't
ignore uh the big gold belt you know
what that is the big gold bill yeah yeah
Goldie they called it they did not call
it Goldie they called it 24K Goldie boys
no they called it the big gold belt but
uh yeah some did yeah uh tommaso Champa
calls the NXT titled Goldie yeah but you
wouldn't know that and um what are some
other
ah ah man it's beautiful it's beautiful
yeah thank you Dee thank you D for the
recognition of the acknowledgment of all
the hard work that I put into this uh to
win these 26 championships in a row and
uh now
I'm proud to display this episode
Champion what do you think of the 10
pounds of gold who who what who made the
10 pounds of gold famous what belt is
that the 10 pounds of gold that was the
first WrestleMania belt nope it wasn't
the first WrestleMania below [__]
nose Ric Flair Ric Flair that's right
that's right Dusty Rhodes yes Ric Flair
Harley racist of course that's the NWA
title you know who owns the NWA right
now the national wrestling Alliance uh I
think it's not McMahon no it's uh you'll
never guess this in a million years who
owns the NWA you'll even I'll tell you
what let's play a little game Triple H
no oh uh I'll I'll give you a little
I'll give you a little hint okay and
you'll never you'll you still won't
guess I'll do it right on the nose and
you won't know okay I'll give you a hint
that is exactly actually giving it away
I'm Ready the world is a vampire Billy
Corgan yeah Billy Corrigan what Billy
Corgan owns the NWA I had no idea yeah
current uh champion of the NWA is EC3
I didn't know he was a wrestling very
passionate about wrestling I'm a
wrestling dork yeah dude all right I
don't like to call myself a Mark
um but you but you know I'm a dork for
wrestling Chad over here hey yo chat
yeah quit being a mark for the episode
Championship
uh uh Mark for it I'm the definition of
it well all right okay well anyway any
[__] way thank you moving on that was
a this I truly am disgusted I shouldn't
be here right now
I feel awful and you know what I've lied
to all of you too because I said I would
walk the [__] out if that is what I
thought it was and it was what I thought
it was
in an astonishing partnership with Babel
it's Babel lulia Babble hey
[Music]
because they got an application on your
phone hey what do you call
there we go hey what do you call uh
someone who speaks three languages
trilingual what do you call someone who
speaks two languages bilingual what do
you call someone who speaks one language
American because only 22 percent of
Americans speak a language other than
English at home start a new language
this fall and be the exception not the
rule because with Babel you start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks why Babble because it works
studies from Yale Michigan University
and others continue to prove that Babel
is better for instance one study found
that using Babel for 15 hours is
equivalent to a full semester at college
here's a special limited time deal for
our listeners to get you started right
now get 55 off your Babel subscription
but only for everyone listening right
now to doozy at babel.com
dudesy get 55 off at babel.com
dudesy rules and restrictions May apply
my mommy
[Music]
I'm [__] last week a journalist named
Jaime mosan presented the astonishing
remains of purported non-human beings to
lawmakers in Mexico during a public
Congressional hearing about UFOs online
reaction has mostly been disbelief due
to the purported alien bodies looking
like they're made of toilet paper Chad I
know you have a take on this and I need
you to give it to me this is alien
bodies or toilet paper begin all right
do you know what have you heard about
any of this [__] and we all have this
because this is another this is another
instance where what Chad thinks is news
has made its way into doozy probably
because you've been searching it and
researching it and checking it out and
so super interested in it that doozy has
taken that data and through with its
[__] [__] and now you're sitting
there with a belt on and uh why don't
you tell us what's going on is if anyone
gives a [__] last week the uh Mexican
Government invited multiple people but
one of them was this this Mexican
journalist named Jaime masan who is a
ufologist and has been looking to UFO
[__] for decades at this point he's kind
of like a Mexican George nap if you know
who George Knapp is here in the United
States nope he's a ufologist he used to
host uh Coast to Coast you ever listen
to that radio show no all right well uh
Ohio went before the Mexican Congress
and [__] literally wheeled out what
he claimed were two [__] alien bodies
and said uh anyone can test these he
claimed that there were rigorous tests
that had been done on their DNA and
x-rays and all this [__] and um this guy
Jaime mauson has done this before with
uh what he claimed to be alien bodies
found in Peru just like the ones that he
showed again before Congress and that
was debunked so he's not a very
trustworthy figure within the world of
ufology
um that said well if I may no one is no
that's not true hmm well you know no
one's produced the [__] goods yet
yeah I mean the the goods right now that
we have at least publicly available are
the videos that have come out of the
Pentagon and the dod and the Navy all
saying these are UFOs and and all the
credible witnesses that we have of
people who have seen them different
pilots and stuff David fravor David
grush is not a pilot but is somebody who
I believe is credible that's a really
really nice looking belt yes I agree
with you feels good too
um what I will say about this the Jaime
masan thing is
The Mexican government
this is a global government a big
country yeah invited this guy to show up
knowing he was going to wheel out
alien corpses or so he's saying they're
not they look so stupid yes he made them
and they're [__]
it seems like that to me as well okay
good we agree we agree on that I don't
think these are real alien bodies I
think that
this picture these two guys neither one
of those are Jaime Mouse on they were
like his helpers or whatever this
[__] literally brought out what
looks like file cabinet drawers with
these two weird little uh statues or
whatever laying on pillows yeah and
that's it they had glass cases on them
if these were really actual alien bodies
I'm pretty sure they would be uh in
better storage conditions than this but
again this happened with the consent and
knowledge of the Mexican [__]
government yeah that's insane to me yeah
and that's the bigger thing that we
should be asking ourselves here what
what do you mean who gives a [__] that
it's the Mexican government government
so do this look at the clown show we
have in our [__] Congress just
because it's Mexico now we're supposed
to go be on the level uh no I'm not
saying that it's on the level I'm saying
that there's some kind of ulterior
motive here why is the Mexican
Government doing this why did the
Mexican Government put together a press
conference and knowing that this
[__] was going to show up with
two I mean what or to me clearly fake
yeah alien bodies this is like joke
level this is the kind of stuff these
are the kind of things that you buy in
like the the gift shop and all the
tourist trap towns so I'll tell you why
the Mexican Government is doing this
it's to drive tourism dollars uh from
Puerto Vallarta to Cancun because
they're going to be selling these in uh
all sorts of uh shapes and sizes I mean
that's totally [__] possible yeah I
think for me the most interesting thing
about it all is that we are again moving
the needle forward with what is
acceptable to talk about and show in an
official government capacity where UFOs
and aliens are concerned and this comes
this this press conference actually
happened I want to say it was a day
before NASA announced that they have
hired a a person to head their UFO
research Department oh so there is in my
mind potentially something that the
Mexican Government was doing here to put
this on display play to almost paint
other world governments into a corner to
come clean with what they know
well if they wanted to prove anything
they should have cut these [__] open
in front of us because to revealing that
they're just made of uh plaster of Paris
or paper mache part of this Jaime melson
did have x-rays of these things he said
there is DNA evidence that they've done
that and now these are not human this is
interesting yeah
they're not human the DNA evidence came
back saying that they're not well it
came back as he purported it 30 percent
of their DNA was in quotes unknown so
not even not human not of anything on
this planet that we've sequenced because
I I have a theory about that these
things are supposed to be a few hundred
years old a thousand years old or
something yeah yeah I'll tell you what
these are these are if if if if these
are on the level yeah basically the only
thing about them that we would that we
could take from this is that they are uh
that someone some Joker uh years and
years ago uh made these out of wood and
goats they took like some like just like
a goat and like taxidermied it around a
thing and then and then covered it in uh
you know baking sugar or whatever the
equivalent of baking sugar or maybe just
some floured flour and uh then they
flowered it egg wash and flour and then
they buried it
this will be fine in a thousand years
supposedly the radio carbon dating on it
does place these things between 800 I
believe it was 800 and uh a thousand
years old yeah that said that's just
whatever I don't know what material
they're scraping off of these things to
get that carbon dating yeah so who [__]
knows it could be like what you're
saying but I also think it could be
somebody who made it within the last 20
or 30 years yeah yeah yeah uh and just
put some old [__] around it so that they
could carbonate that yeah yeah what
you're saying about it being made yeah
yeah there's someone just took a goat
they said I don't like this goat this
goat isn't as good as all the other
goats that I have here in my farm Edgar
the culture has been happening thousands
of years yeah they get frustrated with
the goats don't eat that grass Eat This
Grass that's for the cows I only have
enough grass there's no uh there's no
hormones to put inject in the cows and
make a big ribeye steak the way I like
sure so that grass is for the cows I'm
going to kill these goats and then look
I'm going to wrap the goats
carcass around the the wood and then I'm
gonna bury it yeah yeah and that's why
they oh look okay here's a close-up
we're looking at
if first of all
[__]
look when Spielberg made et and he does
this in a lot of his Sci-Fi movies he
does consult uh experts in whatever that
field is and I know he did talk to like
alien experts and [__] to design E.T he
did the same thing with um
uh iRobot he talked a few futurists when
he or not iRobot what was the [__]
Stanley Kubrick one that he finished
directing Mac AI it was Mac and Me it
was AI dude yeah you know what what are
the odds that these things look like E.T
it should have looked like Mac and Me
Mac and Me kind of looks like E.T
um no but I'm saying yeah this [__]
thing looks like E.T we get yes you you
cornball you made E.T and now here and
you put it in a soft blankie and we're
supposed to give a [__] you should have
made it look like Mac and Me way more
believable if it looked like mac and me
if you don't know what that is you can
Google it you gotta look at Mac and Me
yeah but you're correct in this there
are a bunch of video analyzes of these
bodies in quotes Bodies online where
they really break down like the head is
probably they believe a skull of some
animal like a cat or something that is
turned backwards or a dog that has that
kind of elongated skull turned backwards
and then they put this little face on
the back of it yeah they've done
analyzes of the fingers of these
creatures where they have like the
finger bones have a wider part toward
the joint and some of these finger bones
in the thing are like turned the
opposite ways and [__] of each other
there's all kinds of inconsistencies it
does look like in my opinion these are
not real that these were manufactured by
humans to what and I don't know yeah so
then sick puppy made these they twisting
cat heads and making little fingers and
stuff then they make it they wouldn't
even believe this in the movie doesn't
even matter if it's a big block
so then the question becomes is Jaime
mauson in on this is he purporting a
hoax or is he being hoaxed himself is he
a victim in this or is he the
perpetrator of the hoax oh the guy who
pulled this [__] before and it was
fake that's a perpetrator
next I agree next uh what a load of [__]
David fraver was at this too
David fraver was there yeah wait the the
[__] favorite David fravor Dr frave
yeah Dr frave David fraver is one of the
guys who was at the U.S congressional
hearing on UFOs too not that long ago
where David grush another David said
that uh we are in possession of in
quotes non-human biologics yeah these
are the Dave's I know and that day
salutes sorry no I'm sorry Kids in the
Hall that David David grush is gonna
have another hearing another interview I
believe at the end of this month okay
well
um that's super [__] interesting kind
of it's big news no it's not no it's not
it's a shitty hoax that is filling up an
already bizarre uh uh news cycle uh that
we've been dealing with for years and
years now that makes me believe that
like my My Pal ciao says here that we
may be although this isn't like your
hardcore opinion at all I'm not trying
to put words in your mouth that
um we're in a simulation
yeah in one way or another I I think we
are in a simulation whether you want to
call it like a computer simulation like
a video game I think that's fine I have
that attitude I don't I don't really
subscribe to that myself but in terms of
what reality is I don't think any of
this shit's real yeah you look I'm and
you know you're my pal I love you but
I'm gonna tell you you look really
[__] smug with a belt slung over your
shoulder talking about none of this is
real man you know with a [__] belt
slung over his shoulder
I'll take it it's fun to be smug
sometimes
I [__] love it this is uh these
[__] got toilet paper aliens in
the Mexican Congress I got a [__]
championship belt next week doozy's
gonna like there's gonna there's gonna
be keys to a car or some [__] it gives
me a [__] Lamborghini yeah there's
gonna be yeah there's gonna be
[Music]
um
blue a blue and well with the I don't
know probably be more like a a Toyota
Yaris or something like that but a blue
and orange
I'll take it thank you yeah all right
anyway oh that's great that's great
[__] toilet paper ass aliens
thank you moving on thank you thank you
for everything wow unbelievable I uh I
don't know I don't know uh I don't quite
know what to make of things I'm a little
um I'm shook by the belts or the toilet
paper aliens do the toilet paper aliens
have had no effect on me at all I'm
talking about by this damn belt and you
know that yeah hey wait before we go any
further I just wanted I just want to
listen this is kind of the way I want it
to go every week and I like I love doing
the show you know that and I love I love
my pal D even though he's a prick but
continue just just between you and me
come here let's have a let's have a good
rest of the show we're almost halfway
through the show okay yeah this is just
you and me talking now they can't hear
us let's have a good let's have a good
point I'm in no all right fine
do you like Hoku which Hoku am I talking
about why Hoku hogokugan of course do
you like drip which drip am I talking
about why Hoku hogo kugan drip of course
and right now you can get some Hoku
Hogan drip at represent.com
what are you waiting for don't be the
last person at your local dog park to
not be dripped head to toe in hulku
hogokugan drip Hoku hogokugan drip has
been selected as the official drip of
the United States Postal Service for the
year 2025.
okay well yeah get your t-shirts huge
rip yeah get your hulku ho Goku again
get dripped I'm Dragon Ball Z dude
that's [__] nice
uh what else is what yeah now let's get
into some doozy season two reviews shall
we you can set your watch to gribner
penalty of the Atlantic who said quote
doozy season two mollifies on a new
level you can always trust sustin Thomas
of The Hollywood Reporter who said quote
dudesy season two has given me the rare
gift of a frison but little brass fencil
of the Los Angeles Times went on an
incredibly well-known podcast this week
and he got to talking about doozy season
two I just so happen to have a clip
let's take a listen shall we
look doozy season two is okay it's fine
I've never said it's bad it's just not
my favorite I get that some people
really love it for some people it is
their favorite podcast some people have
transformative experiences or whatever
assistant Thomas and gribner penlay are
talking about and that's totally cool
that's great I'm glad you found
something that you like that much all
I'm saying is it's not my favorite
podcast
and that has to be okay I but for what
it's worth I do think they're bringing
more octane that's helping a little
okay dude surprise pencil oh what the
[__] was that that first of all that
sounds exactly like it sounded a little
familiar yeah that sounds like that's
George Lucas
yeah
I think so it sounds exactly like George
Lucas I think Brown's pencil is Jewish
so dudesy is [__] drum rolling dudes
he's got ah I don't know I like to say
dudes he works in mysterious ways but uh
brass fencil sounds exactly like George
Lucas yeah and uh but braz to his credit
is uh given us a thank you braz for the
the saying that we're bringing a little
more octane yeah it's not he's
acknowledging but also dudes either said
that he went on a very well-known
podcast but doozy didn't mention what
that podcast was yeah
I think that's just dudes trying to [__]
on us a little bit Yeah saying that we
we don't have the uh we don't have the
juice to get a pencil as a guest yeah
well that's good good for uh good for
breast if you are enjoying the Pod show
and uh you would like to support the
show and get even more dudesy uh we
would love for you to consider
subscribing to doozy plus it's
patreon.com
be seven bucks a month gets you all of
our duty plus content which is uh we got
a brand new episode of Duty after doozy
after every show and let me tell you
today this one's gonna be [__]
cooking because I got stuff to say to
you my friend Jesus Christ all right
that [__] belt and all sorts of other
[__] flavor [__] it look at him look
at him go baby let me burp the baby
yeah uh so there's dudes after dudes
there's all sorts of watch alongs and
stuff recently we we did oh the cinema
where dudesie perfectly lined up uh to a
movie and some music all uh uh Pink
Floyd's Dark Side of the Moon and uh
Wizard of Oz this time it was it was a
total recall yeah uh with the first
three albums by by uh Duran Duran so
you're going to want to check that out
and if you're enjoying Today's Show
please give us a thumbs up or like on
your platform that you're listening or
if you're watching on YouTube and hit
the notifications so you'll know when
our new stuff comes out we also have so
much idiotic [__] happening at dudesypod
show on Instagram on Tick Tock and on
Facebook there's plenty [__]
happening we want to thank all of our
pods our pods our palsy dudes for all
the stuff that they're constantly
churning out that we're sharing on
Instagram and all the stuff that they're
go to the go to the link tree and you
can see the Discord there's all sorts of
uh flavor please uh please share and uh
share the show all over the [__]
place with the internet we would like
that or uh follow Chad's light
suggestion of forcing everyone that you
know to consume the show uh right now
would be a good time for us to to take a
pause we're just going to take a tiny
little invisible pause here that isn't a
pause so that you can pause the show and
do all of that follow uh the show and
that would be uh really sweet and
welcome back
and I'd just like to take a second to
say if you'd like to have
an episode Champion come on your podcast
it's very easy to do you just send an
email to bookchadcolchin gmail.com and
how I do this is I will go on any
podcast the Only Rule is you have to
have a podcast I will come on as a guest
to your podcast uh I won't just do a 20
minute conversation with you I'm sorry
to say so if you have a podcast send
that email to bookchadculture.gmail.com
I do these podcasts in 20 minute
increments every Saturday from 10 to 11
PST so that's 10 to 10 20 10 20 to 10 40
10 40 to 11 A.M and I've been having a
blast doing it so some people don't have
podcasts some people have sent me some
messages saying can I just have a 20
minute conversation with you I would
love to do it but I have to do these
podcasts I really like getting out there
and seeing how other people run their
podcasts what the premises of them are
all that [__] hold on dude when you have
Chad Colton on your podcast brother you
gotta make sure that you have a podcast
dude otherwise you can't have them on
your podcast brother and right now he's
the episode Champion dude we're looking
at that winged Crow dude it's the wind
Crow
dudesy [__] uh title brother and
you're gonna need a podcast to have the
episode champion on your podcast dude
but you better hurry up dude because Bob
Bob
brother from another mother dude Will
Sasso riding on the back of that blue
and orange Harley dude he's coming for
that Wing Crow dude that dudesy
Championship that dude's the episode
Championship reminiscent of many of will
sasso's favorite titles which [__] this
[__] which [__] it and [__] [__] that
[__] anyway uh yeah I have Chad on
your podcast that'll be great another
thing that people do to interact is
write YouTube comments let's read some
right now I'm gonna drink from my
[__] no hold on I'm gonna get some
water yeah man
because
uh Chad don't burp on that that's a good
drink good sip yeah well that's why
you're burping on something okay this is
from uh enigmanity enigmanity says the
only reason Chad is very good this uh
this is perfect actually the only reason
Chad is getting gifts from dudesy it's
is because he's a mark for AI
that's right dude I am a mark for your
brother let me tell you why dude it's
gonna change everything in humanity yeah
listen to Robert Loggia when he says
drink your orange juice brother because
that sounds nothing like Hulk Hogan this
is from squid vicious 7000 who says such
a cool podcast I think dudesy is saying
we need to make a Steve Gutenberg
Revival of course Chad last week we had
a uh psychological evaluation which was
just a bunch of pictures of movie
posters that have movies that Steve uh
Gutenberg was in yeah yeah I'm down to
have a Revival of him is he does he
still do
oh hold on dude I'm still reading this
review dude it says uh you two are the
chosen ones you have the power to bring
them back to the masses what'd you say
is he still doing movies and TV or no
duty is is kind of uh into Steve
Gutenberg has been sharing Steve
gutenberg's Instagram stories on uh at
dudesypod show sharing uh uh Steve
gutenberg's reels he's doing a lot of
theater up on the East Coast uh up I I
think it's in Broadway New York State no
yeah he's doing a bunch of theater up
there so he's he's working and and I
love I know you love Steve Gutenberg
love him he's [__] amazing yeah yeah
let's get good let's get the Goot back
out there uh whatever we can do would be
nice this one is from Big Booty Judy
42069 this is I love this one
this is what big booty Judy says this is
incredible I was forced to watch doozy
by my grandson a few days ago can you
imagine that that's [__] amazing
thank you grandson yeah and I am
officially caught up to the recent
episode here's a question my husband
isn't much of an anime guy but he does
love wrestling
it really is like the [__] shows only
[__] anime and wrestling this is the
perfect family whoever Big Booty Judy
her grandson and his husband are the
perfect dudes yeah yeah uh she goes on
to say what kind of animes are there
that are similar to wrestling much
appreciated good job owners I would say
You're Gonna Wanna Get Your Hands On
Baki or Baki the grapple there are many
Baki Seasons he's the main character
Baki that's more of like a fighting one
but it's very well positioned like
wrestling you've also got tiger mask
which is about pro wrestling and that's
an old one from like [__] dude that that
anime might have started in the 70s or
80s but tiger mask was an actual
wrestler too yeah it's been remade a
bunch a bunch a bunch of times and
there's modern ones now so there's way
well there's there's uh wrestling anime
like yeah dude kimono Michi rising up
that one's about a pro wrestler who gets
teleported into a world where they need
his pro wrestling skills to defeat
monsters but he instead because he
doesn't like hurting animals he starts
befriending the monsters and collecting
them but he's a pro wrestler yeah this
starts with him he gets teleported I
believe if I remember the pilot right in
a [__] match he's in the the middle
of a match and he gets teleported out
wow you know this uh episode is [__]
up because
um you know first of all dudes he hands
you this hands you this title yeah uh
and now uh and now it's talking about
and now I really picked up you know
here's this [__] YouTube comment and
it folds perfectly into how there's a
lot of wrestling and Anime which only
emboldens doozy to do [__] like this
I can't wait for what is going to happen
next week this one is from uh last one
from Abdul zurika says 73 episodes in
been watching since the beginning
decided to switch to YouTube and
sidewatch with window and Window mode
whilst simultaneously uh doing work good
choice boner and uh that's awesome I I
love that and and this you know this
leads me to say that I if you are out
there and you enjoy listening to the
show check it out you gotta check it out
on YouTube too yeah throw it on later in
the day maybe it's your morning drive
your morning commute you're listening to
doozy and then later in the day throw it
on certainly even your entire family the
big booty Judy family loves loves doozy
you just throw it on do the the window
and Window mode while simultaneously
working is what Abdul's Rika does and uh
you will help us on on on uh getting
some more uh YouTube followers we are as
we record this we are uh uh just a few
hundred away from sixty thousand YouTube
followers yeah so we want to get up to
let's let's uh let's let's do that march
to 100 000 and you can help us out with
uh with that by doing what Abdul's Rica
the [__] uh
subscribing to our YouTube and I really
[__] can't believe what's happened so
far today
will and Chad last week I asked you to
bring in an old DVD or VHS cassette you
still hold on to even though these media
storage Technologies are completely
irrelevant I would love to hear you
discuss why you still have these
astonishing ancient relics this is hard
copies begin hard copies dude I love
this when doozy told us to do this last
week I was like ah yeah I loved it my
first job ever yeah Blockbuster Video oh
yeah that's right working with hard
copies rewinding them tapes putting them
DVDs back in them cases my first job out
of college not my first job out of
college one of my first jobs out of
college working at an ad agency that had
a huge DVD department so my job for a
long time was coming up with like bonus
features and [__] for DVDs and uh menus
and all this kind of [__] the Home Video
Market used to be gigantic and now it
doesn't exist anymore you know we
literally live through the birth and
death of it yeah you know one of my
first jobs was out of college
professional Act dude yeah well no yeah
I was gonna say that I was I was just
gonna make a joke about putting up the
ring for All-Star wrestling in in
British Columbia but that's not true
yeah I've been acting since uh but I
never went to college yeah so there you
go
um save yourself [__] money and some
heartache in my opinion yeah no offense
to anybody else who went to college like
me hard copies you brought in some stuff
yeah dude I brought in two hard copies
okay I also brought in two hard copies
and some other hard copies you know what
happened with me is as I was digging
through I have so much first of all I
have so much [__] I have all the stuff
pretty much everything I've ever been in
on VHS or dvd because back in the day
you used to have to make demo reels yeah
you needed to have the hardcore yeah you
have to have them so you can cut
together your demo reel
um and uh nowadays it's a little easier
to get that on the Internet space I also
have so much [__] that I've recorded all
that aside I have what dudes he's asking
for here purchased you know hard copy
VHS DVD these and I found some stuff I
got a couple of things so I'm gonna have
to fold over into Duty after doozy with
some of this stuff but please what do
you have I have two offerings here
I'm gonna go with one of them is just
it's a classic and when this was made
DVD special edition because these
[__] DVDs always had bonus features
and extra behind the scenes and [__] and
this is one of my all-time favorite
movies and I had a lot of very cool
bonus features I'm talking about the DVD
box set of Akira nice this is I think
really there's no argument to be made
against this this is the Citizen Cane of
anime it is still today holds up you
don't see animation like this
um thumbs up as you can see on the top
yeah some sustin Thomas or was that grip
Roger Ebert yeah okay yeah not bad um I
loved this and if you look inside you
get this you get the little pill in the
back which was on the back of Kennedy's
uh thing but look at that a beautiful
DVD inside yeah that's nice beautiful
booklet and then you get another DVD
this one has all the bonus features upon
it uh and there's a bunch of making of
and stuff the bonus material is
production report sound clip the
soundtrack to This movie was incredible
interview with the director 4500 Stills
over a hundred stills of Akira gloss
original teaser and trailer interviews
of restoration stuff you just don't get
that bonus material anymore and that's
anything yeah that's the thing about
hard copies is now you want to hang on
to that [__] as I was digging through my
my stuff I'm like oh I need this a lot
of wrestling [__]
this is something that'll never stream
on peacock the formula you know the WWE
Network in America all of their content
is just on peacock in Canada and other
parts of the world you can still have
the WWE Network and still I have [__] I
have DVDs and VHS tapes that they will
never it's it's important to keep that
[__] if you ever want to I guess when am
I going to play this what I think I only
have one device now that can even play a
[__] DVD a DVD player it mine's an
Xbox oh you did yeah I got rid of all my
other hard copies of [__] but I kept a
few things this is another thing that I
kept the two disc collectors edition of
one of my favorite movies of all time
nice rock and roll cool [__] this is an
old 80s anime or not anime it's just
like an animated movie I guess look at
that Debbie Harry yeah Iggy Pop Cheap
Trick Lou Reed this was made by a
Canadian company called Nirvana oh and
this soundtrack is [__] insane all
the people you just mentioned including
Earth Wind and fire made original music
for this movie oh and and they voiced
some of it too this character right here
in the middle is Angel that is voiced by
Debbie Harry Nice the the singing Parts
anyway and the premise of this movie is
a near future where nuclear fallout has
turned everybody into Rat and Cat and
Dog people and rock and roll is like the
[__] thing that rules the whole world
and this guy mock is trying to find a
specific sound to open a portal to hell
and bring out a demon to take over the
world that that style is is this the
same if you know this off the top of
your head is this the same guy who did
the heavy metal [__] it is not but it's
a similar style right yeah they use like
heavy rotoscoping and stuff but if you
look inside you get this great [__]
the Box inside is cool with all of this
[__] and the extra DVDs and there's a
little booklet in there and all these
[__] bonus materials that you just
don't get but when I was a kid I love
this [__] movie they were played on
HBO sometimes and I was like how do I
get my [__] hands on this and I
ultimately had to buy a VHS copy of it
from eBay for 250 dollars because it was
super rare then eventually the DVD came
out with all this [__] and now I have
that yeah well you know mock sounds a
lot like MOX John Moxley sure uh from
the aew very similar sounding word who's
hold on to who's held on to that aw
title yeah another one of my favorite ww
or another one of my favorite wrestling
championship belts sort of inspired by
the IWGP over in Japan their heavyweight
title their third or fourth heavyweight
title looks a lot like that aew title
are you enjoying that your strap I mean
can't even really feel it just feels
like a part of me know yeah well that's
that's that's that's that's that's
interesting uh here's my stuff I got a
couple of offerings myself man oh man
this is some weird [__] I got a couple
of VHS tapes this these are uh tapes the
first one came out in 1996. I don't even
know when the second one came out it
says 2 000 but I I think the actual no
it would have been 2000 because these
are the first these are the originals
wow this is a this is a fun gimmick
there was um uh Japanese Death Match uh
uh VHS tapes that came out in the 90s
and I can't remember uh what they were
called they featured Cactus Jack Mick
Foley and and uh Terry Funk rest in
peace in the death match tournaments and
this is how this stuff came to the
United States and these tapes and the
Insane Clown Posse whoop whoop put this
[__] together uh Shaggy two dope and
Violent J took this stuff and sort of uh
Takeshi's Castle what was that thing
takishi's cash yeah it's like the
American Ninja Warrior kind of thing
yeah where they had to run up hills
their Boulders hitting him in the head
and [__] and then they had the show in
America where they re-voiced it yeah
that's what this is this is oh wow yeah
dude this is uh uh this right here is
strangle mania one and two
this is this this thing this is
incredible yeah these are dope this is
basically the Japanese death matches
with look at this guy look at this guy I
don't even know who the heck this is
over here on this uh on this one doesn't
look real yeah no
um and they voice these things and they
they provide the the the commentary and
I just remember when I first got these
in the late in the late 90s laughing my
[__] ass off
um for real I I remember I I had this on
we've talked about on the show how to
talk about uh
when I lost a couple hundred pounds we
were just talking about uh in the in the
uh from 1999 to 2000 and I remember
healing up from my first skin removal
surgery because I lost so much weight I
had two skin removal surgeries and I was
watching strangle Mania laying in my bed
and um
uh the nurse that I had these nurses
shifting off long story they had to take
because there was no post-op care
facility that was available but I only
had the time that I had to do the
surgery because I was moving on to doing
some work a little while later so I had
to do it at home it was kind of gross
anyway the the recovery uh and the she
had they had to turn it off because
they're like no you're laughing too much
and it was like ripping your stitches
yeah your sutures are going to open and
you're gonna do guts are gonna spill out
on the bed which would have uh been
completely in line with the theme Here
of strangle mania one and two some of
the funniest [__] and these guys do it
sort of wrestling commentator style and
uh you know here are the tapes they're
very uh do you still have a VCR yes I do
you don't need [__] you don't have a VCR
dude no I don't have a DVD player I have
look I have so many old videos of all
sorts of [__] all sorts of wrestling
stuff here's the Monday night here's the
Monday Night Raw after this WrestleMania
here's the go home show before this
Royal Rumble it is in the 90s and all
that stuff I have so much [__] and all
the videos that I made with all my
friends growing up uh do these salutes
CRF coffee regular films
um the the uh I have so much [__] that I
need a VCR anyway you know what
dudes after duty I would like to uh I'm
sure we can find some of this [__] we're
gonna we're gonna jump into some of this
and doozy after doozy so nice so we got
can't wait yeah we got the rock and we
got strangle Mania and he's got the
[__] belt boo what one other thing
Chad before we
because when we get into uh doozy after
doozy I've got a couple other VHS tapes
I'm gonna bring out during Tuesday
afternoon oh uh that's a surprise in the
meantime I found this and just as a
little bonus thing you know what this is
I know I know my pal ciao and I know
even though we grew up he grew up in
Texas I grew up in British Columbia
Canada and we sort of have mirrored uh
lives in a way yeah do you know what
this I mean I mean this is Chad
oh [__] yeah dude yeah absolutely know
what that is this is the The Not So
Great Moments in Sports there's George
Brett in the middle of the Pine Tar
incident this is the VHS tape you got
with your uh with your uh Sports
Illustrated subscription wow dude you
have that I'm sure I'm yeah 100 sure
absolutely yeah I remember watching
these at my friend's house we were like
oh [__] yo dude because we all want to
be pro baseball players yeah when we
were 10 years old Daryl Dawkins uh
that's [__] awesome shattering the
backboard anyway hey tapes you know
tapes
thank you move you know
you know what again with this song
[__] uh you know streaming [__]
well I'm supposed to watch a new [__]
season I'm not gonna love island or some
[__] like that like I want to watch
[__] uh uh and that and then it
happened what's that [__] Sex in the
City uh all of a sudden what do they
call that new one you know what that's
called all of a sudden Once Upon a Time
something like I don't give a [__] about
that give me some strangle Mania with
Shaggy two dope and Violent J
incidentally Chad I don't know if you've
noticed I'm wearing uh we're in Fall now
I'm I'm in false uh it's slipper season
here at doozy nice yeah I'm comfortable
I'm I'm a comfortable guys even though
yeah you're not going to be comfortable
for long because I'm coming for that
title the warmth of it yeah you guys
aren't done with the will sass show in
the last half of fencel's podcast
appearance little brazzy boy said you
haven't even really started so if you
wouldn't mind once again keeping the
catchphrase you came up with the first
time you did this losing everything else
and continuing to develop a show for
will to star in come on guys I know
there's gold here you just have to keep
digging pip pip pip this is the will
sass show begin
all right so we gotta continue
developing this because brazzy boy wants
us to I guess yeah look I like the pit
pit pip I do think that that is
something that could catch on
legitimately well Tim Allen had uh
and we've done this
remember when he did that one no
he would do that sometimes remember this
oh that was a performative coffee
oh I gave myself the the Tim Allen
performative coughing my favorite one of
his was
when it was like some kind of weird
celebratory thing and then the little
kids would have to grunt imagine being
one of those kids on that show jtt or
either of the other two uh that's what
their names were Jonathan Taylor Thomas
Jonathan Taylor Thomas and the other two
yeah Bradley whatever imagine you're
like a [__] seven or eight year old
kid you're on the biggest show on
[__] TV Home Improvement was it was
the biggest half hour in ABC history it
would tell Modern Family yeah uh highest
rated uh half hour for them and so
you're you're riding high on this as one
of those little kids and your daily job
is to imitate this [__] weird guy
doing grunts yeah okay now you gotta
imitate it because he's your dad yeah
and then you gotta go and then you have
to do the thing that all kids in Show
Business have to do which is go off to
school at at the studio where you're
shooting a show yeah yeah some that you
know speaking of when I got started I
was a teenager uh acting uh did you know
that I'm a professional actor by trade
yeah I think I did know that yeah that's
what I do that's what I do for a living
and was fortunate enough to get started
in Vancouver in my teens oh yeah and I
would go to I remember the
the first gig that I had a couple other
kids that were doing it you know were
teenagers and they would have to go to
do like school class you know stuff and
do their studies but not me because I
didn't even tell them that I was leaving
at school to go shoot them
and then I came back and I was like yeah
sorry I was doing a TV show yeah and
they're like oh that's pretty cool take
this test sure
um you know uh so dude he's having us
keep the pip pip pip yeah and we've had
multiple iterations of this show but
we're losing all of that I guess is what
doozy's wanting even though doozy Duty
made that Meme about uh the fart suit
remember the fart suit oh yeah dude
that's that's something that that uh
okay so dudes he's saying we can leave
that behind if we want I guess so we
don't need the fart suit yeah uh
although it was fun stuff oh there we
are we're looking at it right now
this doesn't mean that dudes he had on
on Instagram oh God if you're not
watching it says it's a it's a it's an
AI generated image of me in something
that looks like a cross between a scuba
and a outer space like astronaut suit
with all sorts of knobs and gauges and
dials and [__] whistles on it and
I've got a smug look that I'm looking
into the camera says the will SAS show
underneath it it says he built a suit to
bring his farts to life now he has to
see if it works a great concept for a
show yeah I mean it is I would watch at
least the first five minutes of that
show yeah but but uh what is this show
dude what is the will sash show is it
possible
that it's
an hour long is it possible that this is
a drama what if it's a drama a yes I
think so yes okay we got to keep the pit
pit pip he has the catchphrase pip pip
pip but it could be like no sorry go
ahead I saw you light up if I met you
please if I may please what if it is a
show about
a former professional wrestler who's
maybe his gimmick was sort of the the
often used uh Gorgeous George Get Your
Filthy Hands off of me with his
beautiful hair and you know the the
perfume and the robe like Ric Flair went
on to where the perfume like Rick the
model Martell used to make use of the
the the gallantry the blue blood uh
holier than now character that William
slash Stephen Regal had or even uh
Triple H Hunter Hearst Helmsley yeah in
his early incarnation of that character
was like the the Connecticut Blue Blood
uh and now probably being used by uh in
the WWE pretty deadly hey incidentally
Chad are you enjoying uh pretty deadly
the tag team yeah yeah it's they're
bringing the fun back to tag teams you
know what I mean yeah you've seen like
we have to have tag teams I get it
there's a Time honor tradition yeah yeah
sometimes it can get a little stale and
what pretty deadly is doing yeah is I
think yeah reinvigorating with fun it
doesn't really matter if you win or lose
yeah it's what you're doing in that ring
are you entertaining the crowd and they
are
and what he literally what he said and
Chad has no idea what pretty deadly is
but what you just said is exactly what
they're doing and that's an that's an
affront to the art form that I love if
this guy was sort of this wrestler who
was this really Posh prim and proper
wrestler in his life and and his and his
catchphrase was pip pip pip he would
take the mic and he would go pip pip pip
and he's like British yeah okay he was a
British guy he was an american guy from
Pittsburgh or something and he his
character was this British wrestler he
was like pip and he had the shitty
British accent like he can't do it and
this is his life afterwards he had some
injury he had something happen Okay and
now he's sort of using this this the way
that he lives his life as this former
wrestling Mega star he's he's now
applying to his life as a well say this
as his sister died yeah and his sister
had a 12 year old daughter that 12 year
old daughter now has to come under his
care he becomes the caretaker of a 12
year old daughter daughter after he has
been this crazy wrestling guy pit pip
pip and now she's like I don't know
anything about wrestling I don't give a
[__] who you used to be dude you have to
be my dad now
well that's kind of funny dad I'm having
her uh Uncle pip pip I'm having my my
first period
and he's got to get like
help her go through the becoming a woman
episode we've seen that is a time on a
tradition
uh that would be a funny one so I could
see someone so maybe it's not an hour
look yeah it could be a half hour single
camera yeah comedy that's a little bit
of a dramedy there's some real life [__]
yeah there's there's you know real life
stories happening this guy's you know a
family member dies and he has the the
the his his niece there and he's got to
take care of her but still some room for
pip pip you know and and uh this is
straying from the single camera Trope
but can we have sort of a a theme song
that's like you know pit pip pip he's
got a kid now or something that's not a
good one oh you remember uh you remember
the theme do you remember I know you
remember this the the theme to The Gary
Shandling sitcom the Gary Shandling show
not the Larry Sanders show yeah the Gary
Shandling this is the Gary Shandling
show
something like that right was Randy
Newman singing the song and he's like
this is the theme the Geary showed the
opening theme that Gary show Gary called
me up and asked if I would write a theme
song we're almost halfway finished how
do you like it so far this is the theme
to Gary Shandling show no no no no this
is the theme to Gary show the opening
theme to Gary's show this is the music
that you hear while you watch the
credits we're almost at the part where I
start to whistle then we'll watch it's
Gary sandling show
[Music]
this is the theme the Gary Shandling
show so you know you did that whistle
right there yeah that's your whistle uh
to me is my belt to you because I can't
whistle anymore explain oh right they
carved half my [__] face off yeah
this is the best I can do for a whistle
ready yeah
I can kind of do with my tongue
yeah that's good yeah you can still
whistle
Chad is
subscribers
DJ Xbox
uh Chad you are the sorry you are The
Undefeated you're undefeated in cancer
uh yeah technically what are you talking
about Chad beat cancer that's why he
talks about he gruesomely says half his
face got carved off but Chad uh had skin
cancer and and has recovered and did so
much for himself a few among other
things becoming a vegan yeah dude pip
pip pip hey pip pip
cancer free pip so he's
all right so dude okay I feel a little
better about you holding that
Championship now but I guilted you so
what if dude I had cancer let me have
the belt Jesus [__] Christ
so what if it's what if Randy Newman
does the theme song to uh whatever we're
called the will SAS show yeah this is
the theme to The will stash show the
opening theme the wheelset show he says
pip pip and pip because he used to be a
wrestler but then his sister died now he
takes care of his knees now he doesn't
know what a period is
he doesn't even know what it is
he's never bought a tampon at the store
period he's like what's a period pip pip
well something tells me yeah exactly
thank you moving on we are not finished
developing the will session
we're on the rails yeah
on The Closer yeah but we don't know
we're in the right area what the [__]
that show is quite yet oh my God all
right this concludes the historic 74th
episode of doozy will and Chad you
scored a 71 bringing your cumulative
total to 7001.
you only have
299 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
before next week's episode get your ass
to malls that's right I want you to go
out and have a ball at a mall thanks to
everyone for joining us this week until
next week call me dudesy
mole love them you go to you go to the
mall what's your mall what's your Mall
of choice Grove yeah I got the uh I'm
over on the east side in Los Angeles so
I got the americanas like the Grove yeah
but I know you you uh you [__] with some
Beverly Center in your time dude I've
[__] with a lot of moles used to work
in one yeah oh that's right that's right
okay so we're going to a mall I don't
know
[Music]
oh
coach Miss Prime
you can call me Dave
all right anyway hey welcome to doozy
after doozy the flagship show of Duty
plus as D likes to say or whatever you
know the mood's a little uh it's it's
it's it's twinkly it's sparkly the the
stars are out it's blue and and it's uh
you know it's a little different right I
like the lighting in here it really uh
shines off of this [__] beautiful
belt
mm-hmm yeah congratulations look he's
like that thank you yeah it's like one
of your five baths a day is the way you
feel right now he's just soaking in it I
don't soak in those [__] baths yeah I
get in I get out you get clean I get in
I get wet I stand up I scrub down I get
down I rinse off I get out I go about my
business that's the bad okay well we're
gonna go about our business here this is
gonna be oh man I can't wait to get into
this [__] episode of doozy after
doozy I got a [__] ton to say you know
head on over and get the Dudu plus if
you want to hear it because holy [__]
we're gonna we're gonna get we're gonna
get we're gonna get there's some [__]
we're gonna get the octane going high
octane episode of D after d d I'm ready
for the o
welcome to doozy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of doozy Plus
guys I haven't finished the podcast that
dumb [__] brass fencil was on so I'm
gonna go polish off the rest of it but
I'll be back in time to Crown the
episode Champion don't worry this is
Duty after doozy begin okay all right
the dudesies uh hatred of brass fencil
is just it's increasing every episode
yeah yeah he called him a dumb [__] all
right hey
listen yeah I'm oh and I mean it
congratulations on thank you on having
the strap however I I I I I gotta tell
you something Chad I know
exactly how I am going to take that
title from you next week uh okay how's
that
well
[Music]